the magic word in marketing is test with
any marketing project you're doing make
sure you test it out on a small scale
without losing a ton of money before you
expand it otherwise you could go broke
spending all your money on something you
think is a great idea but you never
tested and you don't having to close
down your company hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe that hunger entrepreneur's
deserve help and today I mention a
question from one of my readers Carissa
who wrote in with a huge email Chrissa
this is crazy and she ends with PS
service email was too long so we have to
work on condensing anyway it's a great
question to her bra I'll summarize her
problem is she sells his great notebooks
she makes them herself and she's made a
deal potentially with a magazine that
wants to send her notebooks out in their
magazine for free as a sample to 40,000
subscribers and give her a two-page
spread in their magazine problem is
going to cost her money to make these
40,000 notebooks and she's worried she
can't keep up with it and she said it
could potentially destroy my business if
I cannot keep up this scares me carissa
this scares me and I'm scared for you I
love taking on big deals i love looking
for new opportunities but you also have
to focus on survival for your company I
hate just launching into a huge new
marketing effort without testing it on a
small scale this is low risk for the
magazine okay you think it's a great
deal but it's not costing them anything
to page advertisement sure there's a
cost to it but a lot of times
advertisements in magazines are not
being filled up so really there's no
cost for them and you're out having to
make all of this inventory for them who
knows is going to work out my main
problem here is are the people on this
list going to then by your notebooks
because if they are it's a great deal if
they're not then you're just out 40,000
notebooks and it might sink your
business you have to find a way to test
it though you have to get a little more
skin in the game from the magazine make
this deal a little bit more fair because
right now it's not
them anything I would have them commit
to give you some kind of advertising
before say I need to make sure that your
readers are my target audience that
they're going to buy from me then I'm
not just going to waste forty thousand
of these notebooks going out have them
give you some advertising before maybe
it's one page maybe it's two pages means
half a page whatever it is something to
show you that they have your target
audience send it out one month before
and see what the response is if people
see your ad and start calling you and
start buying your notebooks then it's
worth doing it's worth testing out
because you know what's going to work if
they put out the ad and nothing happens
don't take the deal you've just saved
yourself a huge amount of money and
heartache that's what I would do with
any marketing initiative see if it works
on a small scale and if it does you blow
it up if this works on a small scale
doesn't just have to be this magazine
you can go it to every magazine that
might be a potential fit there's tons of
options for you the companies that i saw
when i was doing venture capital the
ones that had the best chance of success
the ones who we could find were the ones
who already figured out how to market
themselves on a small scale make some
money coming in they had some kind of
system they weren't making it rich but
they had a way that made them a little
bit of money and they needed money to
expand that that was safe money to give
out they had a good chance of having a
lot of success and the same thing
applies to your business show that it
works prove to yourself that it works on
a small scale have the magazine give you
some kind of commitment so you're
willing to do this but they have to give
you something they have to test it out
with you first a show that it works and
if it works you can bust that out to
every magazine you can think of using
the same model test and then expand and
soon you could have so many customers
that you got to figure out how you're
going to source all these things which
is a good problem to have and it's great
to think about the upside but you have
to protect the downside for me
losing my business that's not an option
loosen my business over our marketing
test is not an option I'd rather not do
it I'm not willing to gamble my whole
company on one marketing initiative and
if the magazine isn't willing to do a
small test for you then they're probably
not the right partner to talk to anyway
because it's costing them nothing and
they have no skin in the game okay good
luck and this applies to any marketing
initiative you're doing any time you're
spending money you want to make sure
you're going to get a return and that
starts from testing small and explaining
from there good luck great question i
hope i answered in time before you went
out made that deal for those of you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below it makes me
want to do more for you and I want to
hear from you please leave a comment
below let me know what you think of this
video and if you have a question for
your business I want to hear it and I
will answer it make your video reply for
you so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode